welcome back to the devops week by
simply learn so far we have mastered the
introduction to devops dockers and
kubernetes devops testing
devops and cloud and the important
devops development tools
so far we have finished the major
fundamentals of devops now the next
important step would be to get prepared
for an interview in today's session we
will be learning the most frequently
asked devops interview questions so
without further ado let's get started
so in today's live session of devops
interview questions we will be
discussing the following questions
first we will go through the gate
interview questions followed by that we
will learn some maven interview
questions then followed by that we have
the selenium interview questions and
then we dive into chef puppet and
ansible based interview questions and
followed by that we have docker
interview questions then we will look
into the kubernetes interview questions
then we have nagios and finally we will
wind up this live session with jenkins
interview questions
now i hope i made myself clear with the
agenda now let's get started with this
live session on devops interview
questions
git is the most popular distributed
version control system used for source
code management
it helps coders to coordinate and track
their code
we have compiled the most important git
interview questions that you might face
in a git or devops interview
so without further ado let's get started
with git interview questions and answers
so let's just get into those source code
management and we're going to focus
specifically on git the reason being is
that get is really the most popular
source code management solution right
now there are other technologies out
there but for the types of distributed
environments that we have uh source code
management with git is probably the most
effective so the first question you'll
be asked when it comes to git is to talk
about the difference between centralized
and distributed version control and if
we look at the way that the two are set
up older technologies such as older
versions of team foundation server
though the current version does actually
have get in it but older versions
required a centralized server for you to
check in and check out of code the
developer in the centralized system does
not have all the files for the
application and if the centralized
server crashes then you actually lose
all of the history of your code now in
contrast a distributed model actually we
do check in our code to a server however
for you to be effective and building out
your solution you actually check out all
of the code for the solution directly
onto your local development machine so
you can actually have a copy of the
entire solution running on your local
machine this allows you to be able to
work effectively offline it really
allows for scalability when it comes to
building out your team so if you have a
team that may be in europe you can
actually then scale that team with
people from asia from north america or
south america very easily and not have
to worry about whether or not they have
the right code or the wrong code and in
addition to that if the actual main
server where you're checking in your
code does crash it's not a big deal
because you actually have each person
has a copy of the code so as soon as the
server comes back up you have to check
back in and everybody's running back as
if there was nothing that happened at
all so one of the questions you'll be
asked is to give the answer to some of
the commands you use for working with
git so if you were to be asked the
question is what is the git command that
downloads any repository from github to
your computer on the screen we have four
options we have git push git fork get
clone and get commit the answer in this
instance would be git clone now if you
want to be able to push code from your
local system to a github repository
using git then first of all you want to
be able to do is connect the local
repository to a remote repository and in
the example you may want to talk about
using the command get remote add origin
and then the actual path to a github
repository you could if you wanted to
actually at this point also talk about
other repositories such as get lab that
you can also work with or a private git
repository that would be used just for
the development team once you've
actually then added the local repository
into your local computer then the second
action you want to use is a push which
is to actually push your local files out
to the master environment so you use the
command git push origin master so one
question you may be asked is what is the
difference between a bare repository and
a standard way of initializing a get
repository so let's look through what is
the standard way so the standard way
using git init allows you to create a
working directory using the command git
in it and then the folder that creates
is the folder that creates all the
revision history related to the work
that you're doing in contrast using the
bear way you have a different commands
for setting that up so it would be git
init dash dash bear and it does not
contain any working or checked out
source files locally on your machine in
addition the revision history is
actually stored in the root folder
versus a subfolder that you would have
with the normal git init initialization
so which of the following cli commands
would you be used to rename a file so we
have git rm git mv git rm-r or none of
the above well in this instance it would
be gate mv a question that you'll be
asked around commit is going to be what
is the process to revert a commit that
has already been pushed and made public
and there are two ways you can address
this the first is to actually address
the bad file in the new commit and you
can use the command git commit dash m
and then put in a comment for why that
file is being removed the second is to
actually create a new commit that
actually undoes all the changes that
were made with the bad commit and then
to do that you would use git revert and
then the commit id and the commit id and
it could be something such as 560e
0938f but you'd have to find that from
the the commit that you had made but
that would allow you to revert any bad
files that you had submitted so there
are two ways of being able to get files
from a get repository and you're going
to be asked to explain the difference
between git fetch and get paul so get
fetch allows you to fetch and download
only new data from a root new repository
it does not integrate any of the new
data into your working files and it can
be undone at any time if you want to
break out the remote tracking branches
in contrast git pull updates the current
head branch with the latest changes from
the remote server so you get all of the
files and downloaded it downloads new
data and integrates it with the current
working files you have on your system
and it tries to merge remote changes
with your local ones so one of the
questions you'll get asked about get is
what is a good stash so as a developer
you will be working on the current
branch within a solution but what
happens if you come up with an idea
where it's something that will take a
different amount of time for you to be
able to complete but you don't want to
interrupt the mainline branch so what
you can actually do is you can actually
create a branch that allows you to start
working on your own work outside of the
main line branch and this is called get
stash allows you to be able to modify
your files without interrupting the
mainline branch so you once you start
talking about branching and git be
prepared to answer and explain the
concept of branching so essentially what
it allows you to do is
have a mainline master branch that has
all the code that the team is checking
in and checking out against but allows
you to have an indefinite number of
branches that allows for new features to
be built in parallel to the mainline
branch and then at some point be
re-introduced to the mainline branch to
allow the team to add in new features
and so if we look through the merge and
get rebase these are the two features
that you'd be using continuously to be
able to talk about how you take a branch
and merge it back into the mainline
branch so on the left hand side we have
git merge which allows you to take the
code that you're creating and merge it
back into the master on the right hand
side what you have is a slightly
different approach this is for projects
where you reach a point in a project
where you go okay we're going to
effectively restart the project at this
point in time and we want to ignore the
complete history that's happened before
that and that's called get rebase and
that would allow you to rewrite the
project history by creating a brand new
mainline branch that ignores all other
previous branches that have happened
before it you can if you want to very
quickly and easily find out all the
files that have been used to make a
particular commit so when somebody asks
you the question how do you find a list
of files has been changed in a
particular commit you can actually say
that all you have to go is find the
command get diff dash tree dash r and
then the hash that you would use for the
commit and that would actually then give
you a breakdown of all the files that
have been made with that particular
commit a question you'll be asked when
you're talking about merging files is
what is a merge conflict in git and how
can it be resolved so essentially a
merge conflict is when you have two or
more branches that are competing with
commits in git and you have to be able
to determine which is the appropriate
files that need to be submitted and this
is where you would go in and to actually
help resolve this issue you'd actually
go in and manually edit the conflicted
files to select the changes you want to
keep in the final merge so let me go
through the steps that you would take to
be able to illustrate this when you're
talking about this particular question
in your interview now there are
essentially four stages the first would
be under the repository name you want to
select a pull request and you want to be
able to show how that pull request would
be demonstrated inside of github so
within the pull request there's going to
be a highlight of conflict markers and
you'll be able to select which conflicts
and you want to keep on which you want
to merge and which ones you want to
change so it's a step through how you
would actually resolve a merge conflict
and the first step would be under github
you want to be able to pull the
repository name and then the pull
request around that repository in the
pull request list click the pull request
with a merge conflict and that you'd
like to be able to resolve they'll pull
up a file that will list out all of the
conflicts for you near the bottom of
that file will be a list of the requests
that need to be resolved and then if you
need to make a decision on which
branches you want to keep or which ones
you want to change that will have to be
something you have to put in
instructions inside of the file you'll
actually see that there are conflict
markers within the instructions which
are going to ask you which files you
want to change which ones you want to
keep if you have more than one merge
conflict in your file scroll down to the
next set of conflict markers and repeat
steps four and five until you resolve
all of the conflicts you will want to
mark your file as resolved in github so
that the repository knows that you are
having everything resolved if you have
more than one file with a conflict then
you want to go then onto the next file
and start working on those files and
just keep repeating the steps we've done
up to this point until you have all the
conflicts resolved and then once you
have all of the resolutions created then
you want to select the button which is
commit merge and then merge all your
files back into github and this will
take care and manage the resolution of
the merge conflict within github so you
can also do this through command line
and with the command line you want to
use get bash and so you want to as a
first step open up get bash and then
navigate to the local git repository in
command line by using the cd change
directory and then list out the the
actual folder where you actually are
putting all of your code and then you
want to be able to generate a list of
the files that are affected with the
merge conflict and in this instance here
you can actually see the file
filestyleguide.md has a merge conflict
in it and as before with working with
github you actually go through and use a
text address and use any text editor but
as you go through and edit out what you
want to keep and what you want to
manage in your conflict so you actually
have a resolution that's been created so
that you'll be able to then once you
you're using the conflict markers you
can actually merge your files together
so that the solution itself will allow
you to incorporate your commits
effectively into the resolution once
you've gone through and applied your
changes you're able to then merge the
conflicted commits into a single commit
and able to push that up to your remote
repository welcome everyone to this
topic in which we are going to talk
about that what exactly is the different
maven interview questions here now in
this one we are going to talk about what
are the different questions some couple
of questions we are going to go through
and we'll try to understand that what
exactly the answers are now uh let's
talk about the first question over here
so what exactly is in maven here so
maven is nothing but a kind of a popular
open tool uh open source build tool
which is available there now before
maven there were a couple of build tools
which was present like and and you know
a lot of other legacy tools was present
there but
after that maven is something which was
released as an open source tool and it
really helps the organization to uh
automate some couple of build processes
and you know have some particular
mechanisms like build publish and deploy
of different different projects at once
itself so it's a very powerful tool
which can really help us to do the build
automations we can integrate them with
the other tools like jenkins and you
know we can automate them we can
schedule the builds so a lot of various
advantages we can get with the help of
this tool here it's primarily written in
java and it can be used to build up
various other kind of projects also like
c sharp scalar ruby etc so all these
other typical tools can also be built up
with the help of this tool
so this tool is primarily uh used to do
the uh particular development and
management of the artifacts in the java
based projects so uh for most of the
java projects nowadays this is the
default tool and it's already integrated
with the eclipse also so when you go for
a new project automatically uh it will
be created for a java project you can
use it for other languages also but yes
default choice of java of of the java
programming language is maven build tool
only
now let's talk about next question so
what does the maven help with so may
when apache maven helps to manage all
the processes such as build process
documentation
release process distribution deployment
preparing the artifact so all these
tasks is being primarily taken care by
the apache maven so this tool simplifies
the process of project building it also
increases the performance of the project
and the overall building process so all
these things are something which is
being taken care by the specific maven
tool here
so it also uses the particular uh you
know it downloads the jar files of the
different dependencies for example if
your source code is dependent on some of
the apache web service
jar files or some of the other
third-party jar files in that case you
don't have to download those jar files
and keep in some repository or keep it
in some lib directory you just have to
mention that dependency in the maven and
that jar file will be downloaded during
the build process and will be cached
locally so that's the biggest advantage
which we get with maven that you don't
have to take care of all these
dependencies anywhere into your source
code system so maven provides easy
access to all the required information
it helps the developer to build the
projects and uh without you know even
worrying about the dependencies
processes or different environments or
different because it's in a kind of a
tool which can be used in any platform
linux or windows so they don't have to
do any kind of conversions so all they
have to do is that they have to just add
new dependencies and that should be
updated into the pom file and depending
on that dependencies the source code
will be built up and they don't have to
refer any kind of third party jar files
so they don't have to play with the
class bars during the build process so
no customizations is actually required
with this one now the next question is
that what are the different elements
that may one take cares of so there are
different kind of elements which is
being taken care by maven so uh
these particular parameters are elements
are bills
dependencies reports distribution
releases and mailing list so these are
the typical different different uh
elements which is being taken care by
the maven during the build process and
during the preparation of the builds
here so all these things you can they
can explore they can extract on that
part and they can fully understand that
how they can work on all these different
different processes now next question is
that what is the difference primary
difference between the and and maven
first of all both of them are primarily
used for the javascript so and is the
older version and maven is something
which was launched after the ant here so
and has no formal conventions like so
which can be uh you know coded into the
build.xml file there but yes the maven
has convention so information is not
required as such in the palm.xml file
there so ant is procedural whereas maven
is declarative over here so and does not
have any kind of life cycle so it
depends on you that how you program the
and there but
maven is having a lot of life cycles
there which we can configure we can
utilize so the uh and related scripts
are not reusable because you cannot
reuse it and you have to do some kind of
customizations in order to work on that
but yes maven is not having much of the
project related any kind of dependencies
they can be easily reusable there
because there is nothing about the
palm.xml file it's just the artifact
name and the dependencies which is uh
something we can override or we can
change and then the same palm.xml file
we can reuse as such for the new project
also so that is where the reusability
comes into the picture now and is a very
specific build tool so we don't have to
there is no plugins as such which is
available there you just have to code
everything that what build process you
want to prepare
whereas in case of maven we have the
concept of plugins which can really help
us to understand that how we can make or
use of these plugins so that we can have
the reusability implemented so these are
some of the differences which is
available there between the and and
maven here now next thing is that what
exactly isn't palm file all about so
palm file is nothing but it's kind of a
xml file which is available there and
it's have having all the information
regarding the project and the
configuration details so it primarily
used over here that how the
configuration needs to be done and how
the setup should be performed as such
here so palmer xml file is the build
script which we prepare uh you can
prepare it uh using a particular
component or you can have a particular
mechanism or if you feel that you want
to have some kind of setup so all these
things typically can be implemented can
be done with the help of build tools so
build tools can be really helpful for us
to do the automations and it can really
help us to understand that how some
build processes we can automate with
simply with the help of palm.xml file
here so the developers usually put up
everything inside these uh dependencies
in the palm.xml file here so this is the
file which is uh usually present in the
home directory it's in the current
directory so that once the build is
triggered it will be picked up from that
directory and according to the steps
according to the content of the pom.xml
file the build will be processed or will
be created here now what i'll include
into the palm file here so the different
components which is included into the
palm dot xml file here is the
dependencies
uh developers and contributors plugins
plugin configuration and resources so
these are the typical components which
is a part of a permanent xml file which
can be uh same for a lot of projects you
can do some customization and then the
same palm file can be reused for the
other projects also now what are the
minimum requirement of the elements
which is there for a palm for uh powered
xml file so without which the palm xml
file will not be validated and will will
be getting a kind of validation errors
so the minimum required elements are
project root
model version so it should be 4.0.0 the
group id of the project the artifact id
of the project and the version of the
artifact these are the minimum things
which we want to define so that we can
understand that what kind of artifact we
are trying to prepare or we are trying
to create here so these are the minimum
required elements which is required in
the palm.xml file without which the
validation of the palm file will fail
and the build will also fail here
now what exactly is the mint uh with the
term called build tool so build tool is
an essential tool is a kind of a process
for building or compiling the source
code here so it's needed or it's
required for the below for generated
processes if you want to generate the
source code if you want to compile the
source code you want to generate the
source code you want to generate some
documentation from the source code you
want to compile the source code or you
want to package the source code whether
it's a jar file it's a war file or it's
a er file so whatever the packaging mode
you want to select you will be able to
do it with the help of the particular
build tool here and if you feel that you
want to upload these particular
artifacts to the artifactory whether
it's on remote machine or locally there
so that also you can do it with the help
of this particular build tools here so
build tools can be helpful in doing a
lot of activities for the developers
now one of the different steps which is
involved to install maven on windows now
all you have to do is that you have to
just first of all download the uh tar
file from the maven apache maven
repository there once that is done so
what happens that you have to set up
some couple of environment variables now
if you download the java jdk using the
exe file in that case the java
underscore home will be configured
automatically but if it is not available
and you're not able to run the java
command line in that case you have to
set up the java underscore home and then
similarly for maven you have to go for
the maven underscore home that
particular variable you have to
configure now once that is done all you
have to do is that you have to edit the
path variable so the bin directory of
the maven extracted a folder you have to
put it up into the path variable and
once that is done what will happen that
you will be able to check the latest
version the version of the maven over
there if it is like some old version
again you have to extract the latest
version and do the steps all together
again so these are some of the ways that
in which you can actually go for the
installation or the configurations of
maven on the windows platform
now what are the different steps which
is involved for the installation of
maven on ubuntu so ubuntu it's fine you
just download the package of java jdk
there once the jdk is installed over
there what you can do you can simply go
and say that yes i want to search for a
particular maven
uh package which is available there so
once the jdk is installed all you have
to do is that you have to configure the
java underscore home
m3 and just go
and disco home and the path variable
once all the path variables are
something which is configured then you
will be able to check the latest version
like whether it's uh the version is
correct or we are getting the standard
version over here or not over here so
that's the main mechanism that how we
will be able to you know configure the
maven on ubuntu here now what exactly is
the command to install to char into the
locals repository now sometimes what
happens that we are not able to fetch
like some dependencies not present on
the uh particular central repository
minimum repository or your artifactory
repository in that case you have some
third-party jar which you want to
install locally onto your repository so
in that case we can go for
the uh but we can download the jar file
there and then we can run the command
called mvn install install hyphen file
and then we are giving the path like
hyphen d file where the path of the file
should be provided now once that is done
so what will happen that in the local
dot m2 directory this specific artifact
will be downloaded and will be installed
there so this is a mechanism where you
will be able to configure or you will be
able to set up the artifacts locally the
java file locally here in the local
repository so next question is that how
do you know that the version of the
maven being used here so the version of
the maven is pretty easy to calculate so
all you have to do is that you have to
just go for mvn and space hyphen iphone
version the moment you do that it will
let you know that what jdk or what java
version you are using and it will also
show you that what particular maven
version you're going to use here so all
that details you will be able to get
with that particular command here
now what exactly is the clean default
and frightened variable here so these
are the build cycles which is available
there in within maven so these are the
built-in build cycles so for clean what
happens that this life cycle will help
you to perform the project cleaning so
usually during the build there are some
files which is created into the target
directory so the clean life cycle is
essentially helping us to clean up all
that directory all that particular
target directory and when we talk about
the specific default so default
lifecycle handles the projector
deployment that is the default uh
lifecycle and site is something which is
uh you know helpful for creating the
site documentation
you know it's kind of a life cycle which
is available there so clean default and
site are the different life cycles which
can perform different different kind of
uh attributes or different tasks here
next question
what exactly is a maven repository so
maven repository refers to the
directories of the package jar files
that contain metadata now the metadata
refers to the palm files relevant to
each project so here you can able to get
your artifacts uh stored there you can
download these artifacts also during the
maven build if you put up that
dependency you will there are different
kind of repositories which is available
there one is the local repository one is
a remote repository and one is the
central repository so these are the
different typical type of repositories
which we have where we can store the
artifacts also and from where we can
download the artifacts also whenever
required now the first one is the local
repository so local repository refers to
the machine of the developers itself
where all the project related files are
stored there now whenever we work on the
uh particular maven so there is an in
the home directory dot m2 folder is
created now usually whatever the
artifacts downloaded from artifactory or
from the
maven repository it gets cached locally
there and once it is downloaded next
time it will not download the same
artifacts of the same dependency
altogether again so this local
repository is something which is
available locally on the developers
machine only so it contains all the
dependent jars which a particular
developer is downloading during the
maven build now remote repositories
refers to the repository which is
present on the server and uh with from
where we will be downloading the uh
particular dependencies so the when when
we are running the maven build on a
fresh machine so usually over there the
local repository does not exist so in
that case what happens that the dot m2
directory is empty but the moment you
run the build what will happen that the
artifacts or the dependencies will be
downloaded from the remote repository
and once it is done once it's uh
downloaded it will be added or it will
be downloaded cached locally there and
it will be
helpful in the future run so that will
be uh considered as a local repository
because all the artifacts all the
dependencies are downloaded there and
central repository is something which is
known as the maven community where all
the artifacts is available there so
usually we cache or we mirror these
central repositories as our particular
remote repositories because it could be
a possibility that these remote
repositories are something which we are
hosting into our organization and
central repository is something which is
available centrally for everyone to use
it so
these are something you know some kind
of repositories where each and every
artifacts will be stored and anyone will
be able to have the access to these
particular artifacts here so these
artifacts are
every artifacts every open source uh
artifacts is something which is
available over there to these central
repository now how does the maven
architecture really work here so the
main architecture really works in the
three steps the very first step is that
it reads the palm.xml file here that's
the very first step second it downloads
the dependencies uh defined in the
panel.xml file into the local repository
from the central or the remote
repository here once that is done so it
will uh you know create or generate the
reports according to the life cycles
which you have configured whether it's a
clean install
site
deploy package or whatever the life
cycle you want to trigger you will be
triggering that particular life cycle
and corresponding to that the build or a
specific task will be performed so these
are the three steps in which the overall
build or any kind of uh execution of
palmer xml file really happens here now
what exactly is the maven build
lifecycle so maven lifecycle isn't
nothing but collection of steps here
that needs to be uh followed for doing a
proper build of a project here so there
are primary three built-in uh cycles
which is available there default which
handles the project deployment
clean which handles the project uh
cleaning there and site which handles
the creation of the project sites
documentation so these are the three
primary built-in build cycles life
cycles which is available as such
now so build lifecycle has you know
different kind of phases or the stages
here because in the previous particular
slide we were talking about with what
are the different uh particular build
life cycles which is available there but
these are the different phases like what
are the different step-by-step
executions like for the deep down which
is available there inside a specific
maven build lifecycle so here you can
see that it's compiling then the test
compile test execution is there then
package integration test to verify
install and the lastly deploy here so
these are the different build phases
which is available as such over here so
what exactly is the command to use to do
a particular maven site so mvn site is
something which is used to create a
maven site here now usually whatever the
artifacts is prepared that will be
prepared in the target directory so here
also you will be able to see a site
directory which is available there in
the target directory which you can refer
for the site documentations what is the
different conventions used while naming
a project in may 1 so usually
it involves three components
so the full name of a project in maven
includes first of all the group id
uh for example count.apache
com.example so these are some of the
particular way that where you can
provide the group id artifact id can be
exact project name like maven project or
whatever the project you are creating so
sample project example project so these
kind of things will be there in the
artifact id and lastly is the version
like which version of your artifact you
want to prepare like 1.0.0 hyphen
snapshot
2.0.0 so like this information you are
providing that what particular version
you are trying to configure here now
let's move on to the intermediate level
where we will be having little bit more
complex questions related to the maven
here now what exactly is a maven
artifact now usually what happens that
when we do a build process as an end of
result of the build process we will get
some artifacts for example when we build
a.net project so there we will be able
to have exe or dll files as an artifacts
similarly in case of maven when we do a
build process there we get the different
kind of artifacts like depending on the
packaging mode like jar file
var files or the er files here so these
are something which is you know getting
generated during the build process
during the main process and you can
store them into your local repository or
you want to push them to the remote
repository it's something that totally
depends on you so maven is a tool which
can help you to create all the artifacts
whether it's a jar file whether it's a
var files or whether it's a er file here
and every artifact is having three
attributes the first one is the group id
the artifact id and a particular version
and that's how you will be able to
identify a full-fledged artifact as such
in maven so maven is not about only the
name of the jar file it's actually
referring to the attributes like crop id
the artifact id and the version of the
artifact here now what are the different
phases of the clean life cycle here so
clean is something which is being used
to clean the target directory so that a
fresh build can be triggered there so
there are three steps pretty clean clean
and post clean here so if you wish that
you want to override the particular life
cycle configurations and you want to run
some particular steps before the clean
activity so you can do it into the
pre-clean and if you want to do it like
some steps after clean then post clean
can be utilized now what are the
different phases of the site life cycle
so pre-site
site post site and site deploy so these
are the different phases which is
available there in the site life cycle
what is exactly we meant by the maven
plugin now
this is the huge difference between the
ant and even here because in and we were
not having this that much support of the
plugins and that's the reason why we had
to deal with all the build
configurations
so we have to simply put the overall
build process that how the build should
be triggered but that is not something
which is there in case of maven in maven
we have a lot of flexibility because we
can actually put up what exactly build
configurations we want to put here we
can put some features like important
features over here in maven and uh these
plugins we can utilize for example i
want to perform a compilation now i
don't really want to do any kind of
configurations in this one so what i can
do is that i can simply use the
compilation plugin in maven and that can
really help me because
i don't have to unnecessarily write or
rewrite the configuration that how the
compilation should be done it's
something which is pre-configured or
pre-written in these plugins that i can
simply import the plug-in and i can do
the build process or the compilation
process in a pretty standard mode so i
don't really have to do any kind of
workarounds with that and simply with
the small automations i will be able to
reach that how these maven plugins can
be integrated into my palm or xml file
and i can desire or i can have some
particular procedures and some steps
executed there so that's the biggest
benefit which we really get with the
help of movement plugins now why exactly
the pavement plugins are utilized so to
create a jar files to create the var
files to compile the code files to
perform the unit testing to create the
project documentation and to create the
project reports so there are a variety
of things in which we can actually use
these maven plugins through the
integrations within the palm.xml file
there so it's all about the plugins you
just import the plugin and that desired
activity will be performed there now
what are the different type of plugins
which is there so
you can have either build projects uh
for performing the build activities you
can have some build plugins for
reporting plugins also there which can
be only generated or utilized to
generate the reports to process the
reports and do any kind of formatting or
any kind of processing on the reports
here so that is where the reporting
plugins are utilized now what is exactly
the difference between the convention
and the configuration in maven so
convention is in particular process when
the developers are not required to
create the build processes so
configuration is when you know the
developers are supposed to create the
build processes so the users do not have
to rectify the configuration in detail
and once the project is created it will
automatically create a structure so they
must specify every in case of
configuration you have to provide each
and every details so that's how the uh
configurations really happens because um
you have to put every detail into the
power xml file and that's how the
particular configurations really work as
such so this is the huge difference
between the conventions and the
configurations here
now
so why exactly said that maven uses
conventions over the configuration so
maywen pretty much does not puts any
efforts like on the particular
developers that they have to put each
and every configuration so there are
some ready-made
plugins which is available there and
pretty much we are making use of that so
that in such a case we don't have to
worry about the executions and we will
be able to pretty much work on that
so conventions like maven uses the
conventions incident of the
configurations so the developers just
you know they don't just have to create
the movement project the rest of the
particular structure will be taken care
automatically so they are not uh you
know expecting that the developers
should be doing the configuration work
and everything should be taken care in
such a way that you just have to start
the things and rest of the things should
be taken care by the maven itself so
maven will be
responsible because they do the plugins
it will be responsible to set up the
default architecture the default folder
structures and all you have to do is
that you have to just
place the source code in the desired
folder structure here so that's
something which you need to do as on
particular developers so what exactly is
the maven order of inheritance here so
the order of inheritance is the settings
cli parameters
parent palm and the project bomb which
means that if you have some
configuration and settings that will be
the highest value then the cli
parameters are there then the parent
palm is there and then the project bomb
so this is the way that how the uh
particular parameters or the
configurations will be picked up by the
may one so that's the order so what does
the build life cycles and the phases
imply in the basic concept of maven so
build life cycles consist of a sequence
of build phases and each build phase
consists of a sequence of goals when a
phase is run
uh all the goals related to that phase
and its plugins are also compiled so you
will be able to have a lot of particular
goals which is residing inside of phase
there and similarly life cycle is
nothing but a kind of a sequence of the
different phase so life cycle comes in
the top then it comes on the phases and
then it comes on the goals here now what
is the terminology called goal in case
of maven the term a terminology goal
refers to the specific task that makes
it possible for the the project to be
built and organized so it's something
which we can run so it's an actual
implementation which is going on there
for example in the build process in the
build phase i have a different goals
like clean install package deploy these
are the different typical uh goals which
is available there which i can execute
into the main one here so these are the
different goals like uh which we can
execute and which we can run during a
maven build next question is what is
exactly meant by the term dependencies
and the repositories in maven here so
dependencies refer to the java libraries
which we usually put up into the
pound.xml file there now what happens
that sometimes our source code is
requiring some java files like a
secondary jar files for performing the
build process so instead of downloading
it and storing it into the class path
for during the build process we just
have to specify the dependency of that
artifact what dependency we need to put
and once that dependency is put up there
we will be able to have that jar file
downloaded and cached into the local
repository during the maven build
project now if the dependencies are not
present in your local repository then
maven will try to download it from the
central repository and again if it is
not a
you know
it's something which is available which
is downloaded from the central
repository then it will be cached
locally into the local repository so
that's the cycle which is being
implemented and utilized during this
process
now what exactly is in snapshot in maven
so snapshot refers to the version
already available in the movement report
repository it signifies the latest
development copy that's what we do with
the case of snapshot here so meven
checks for a new version of snapshot in
the remote repository for every new
build so during the build process like
you know a new snapshot version is being
downloaded and the snapshot is updated
by the data service team which
with updated source code every time to
the repository for each maven build so
snap short is something which we will be
using like very frequently we will be
updating to that and frequently we will
be updating the version to that and we
will try to explore and we will try to
do the modifications now what are the
different type of projects available in
maven so there are thousands of java
projects which you know uh can be
utilized or we can be uh implemented by
my one here so this helps the as the
user that they as they no longer have to
remember every configurations to set a
particular project for example spring
boot spring mvc spring boot etc these
are the different projects which is
already available in maven so most of
the we have already discussed that
for the job-based projects maven is
something which is you know considered
as by default so a lot of organizations
are actually using it for you know
storing or utilizing it for the
particular maven project now what
exactly is the maven uh archetype over
here so maven octave refers to a maven
plugin that is uh entitled to create a
for project structure as per its
template these archetypes are just
project templates that are generated by
maven when any new project is created
there so this is something which we are
using so that we will be able to create
a fresh new projects right so let's go
on to the advanced level of this maven
questions now what exactly is the
command to create a new project based on
an archive type so mvn archetype
generate is used to create a new java
project based on the archetype now this
will take up some parameters from
as an end user from you and depending on
that parameters it will create the
palm.xml file it will create the source
directories uh inside that main java
test all these different couple of
directories directory structures will be
automatically created now why we require
this command so that if you are going to
create a project from scratch from the
uh from the day one this command will
help you to have all the folder
structures created and then further on
you can put up your source code and
those files as such in this folder
structure so that's how is the mechanism
that we will be able to see that how the
setup can be performed really over here
now what does maven clean implies now
movement clean is a plug-in that uh
suggests that it's going to clean the
files and directories there so whenever
we do a build process usually in the
target directory we have some class
files some jar files or whatever the
generated source code which is available
that will be present in the target
directory so the maven clean is
something which is available which is
going to clean all these directories and
why we are doing this directly structure
cleanup so that we will be able to do a
fresh uh build process and there should
not be any kind of
issues as such over here so that's the
main reason why we are looking forward
for this uh particular mechanism or for
this uh particular changes as such here
now so what exactly isn't build profile
all about so build profiles refers to
the set of configurations uh where we
can have like typically two different
kind of build processes there so if you
feel that the same palm.xml file you can
use you want to run for different
different uh particular configurations
so that you will be able to do pretty
much with the help of this component so
build profile is used to do a
customization processes so that you will
be able to have the process and you will
be able to
perform the configurations and the
setups all together there so that's a
very important aspect to be considered
that which we need to uh discuss when we
talk about the build profile so build
profile whenever you feel that you want
to do some customizations and you want
to proceed with the setup so that's
where it's utilized next thing is that
what are the different type of build
profiles which is available there so the
build profiles can be done on for a
particular project like per project you
can do you can uh even do the build
profiles in the settings.xml file also
and if you feel that you want to do it
into the global settings.xml file so
that also you can do as such over here
so there are different ways in which you
can do the customization and once the
customization is done you will be able
to have the different ways of doing the
setups and the configurations over there
so what exactly is meant by the uh
particular system dependencies here so
let's talk about that also so system
dependencies refers to the uh particular
mechanisms where we feel that how the
dependencies should be uh you know
present there so that is something which
is having a scope of system there so
these dependencies are commonly used to
help me one know the dependencies that
is being provided by the jdk system
dependencies are mostly used to resolve
the dependencies on the artifacts that
are provided by the jdk so these
dependencies are somewhat which is being
utilized and used over here so that we
will be able to implement and go ahead
through the system dependencies what is
the reason for using an optional
dependency here so optional dependencies
are used to decrease the transitive
burden of some libraries so what happens
that when you download an artifact when
you put up a dependency so it could be a
possibility that some dependencies as in
particular optional can also be
downloaded now these are not always
required but yes sometimes what happens
that these are downloaded so that you
don't have to put uh each and every uh
artifact or dependency into the powder
xml file for example you're trying to
download some apache tool and with that
some like three four jar files or three
four another dependencies are also
getting downloaded now if you are using
that dependencies that totally create
because you don't have to put that uh
list or that entry in the dependency
list in the power xml file and that can
really save your time but if you feel
that you don't want to have them and you
these are the optional ones and you
really want to
get rid of that so that also you can
exclude while downloading any kind of
dependencies so these are the optional
ones which depending on your requirement
you can utilize you can
process and if you feel that you don't
want to get it you won't want to process
it you can simply ignore it and you can
get rid of that also now what is a
dependency scope and how many type of
dependencies scope are there so there
are different type of dependency scores
which is there which is used on each and
every stage of the build here so compile
provided runtime test system import
these are the different kind of
dependency scopes which we have using
which we can define that when exactly we
want to go ahead for a specific build
process so depending on your requirement
you can explore all these build scopes
and you can get benefits out of that
what is exactly an intransitive
dependency in may one so maven avoids
the need to find out and specify
libraries that our own dependencies
require by including the transitive
dependencies automatically so transitive
dependency says that if he
depends if x depends on y and y depends
on z then x depends on y and both there
so which means that you are not
dependent on one artifact you also need
the z artifact there with the y artifact
so that is what you need to do so that
you will get both the dependencies there
because this is normal that if you are
trying to download some particular
artifacts or download some dependency
and that dependency is also dependent on
some other artifact or some other jar
file then you have to include both of
them so this is something which you will
be able to get so that
you uh can easily download all these
dependent jar files also and the maven
build can be success how can a maven
build profile can be activated so even
build profile can be activated through a
different ways so
explicitly using the command
command line you can talk about that
which profile you want to execute
through maven settings you can do uh
based on environment parameters os
settings and present and missing files
so these are the different ways in which
you can actually activate that which
particular profile you want to have so
profiles configurations can also be
saved in various situations and various
files and from there you will be able to
refer that which file you want to refer
as such now what is meant by the
dependency exclusion the exclusion is
used to exclude any transitive
dependency because you never know that
if you are trying to put up a dependency
uh entry in the power x1 file that
artifact is also further dependent on
another artifact so in order to feel in
order to see that you want to exclude
that dependent artifact which is being
automatically downloaded that also we
can exclude with the help of exclusion
so you can
avoid the transitive dependency with the
help of dependency exclusions here so
what exactly is in mojo so mojo is
nothing but maven plain old java object
here so it's an executable goal in maven
and a plug-in refer to the distribution
of such moses so moses enable the maven
to extend its functionality that already
is not founded in so it's kind of an
extension which is there and using this
we can get some additional benefits and
some executions over there so what is
the command to create a new project
based on a hard drive so again archetype
is something which we normally use to
create the new projects now you can give
the parameters in the command itself or
you want it to in in kind of an
interactive mode where it will take the
parameters from the end user and
according to that the project will be
created onto hard drive or onto server
wherever you wish you want to create you
can create a new project
so explain about the maven settings dot
xml file so main settings.xml file
contains the elements that are used to
define that how the human execution
should be there so there are different
uh settings like local remote central
all these different repositories are
configured as such over here now in this
case what happens that usually the
configurations are done in such a way
that it can you know go for the
executions it can go for the build
process and the complete executions can
be uh involved and can be achieved as
such here so all these executions are
something which we can really perform
and uh here we can put some credentials
how to connect to the remote repository
how to connect to remote repository all
that stuff is something which we talked
about over here what exactly is a meant
by term superbomb here so superform
refers to the default bom of maven so
the moms of maven can't write from so
it's nothing but a reference to a parent
bomb which is available there that is a
super bomb so if you define some
dependencies in that super pump
automatically the uh child pom will also
be able to inherit all those
dependencies so we can put some uh
executions like we can put some
configuration in the super pump so that
if multiple uh projects are going to
refer that they should be able to refer
that easily so that's the reason why we
primarily use the super pump so that we
can have the execution some processes
uh put up over there and all the other
projects should be effort to refer or
inherit from there so where exactly the
dependencies are stored so dependencies
are stored like in different locations
like you have the local repository
remote repository is there local
repositories on the local developers
machine and remote repository something
which is available on a server in form
of artifactory in this session we shall
make sure that you get to know about all
the important selenium interview
questions that you might be asked in
your upcoming selenium interview
selenium tester or selenium developer is
one of the most popular jobs in devops
domain
according to eye data labs a research
company which uses data to provide
industry insights found that nearly 31
percent of software testing tools market
belong to selenium in the year 2018.
the stats tell a lot about how preferred
selenium is all across the world
selenium skills are highly in demand as
the automation testing market goes on
increasing
professionals with these skills are hard
to find so there are ample amount of
jobs in the market for skilled
candidates companies are even willing to
go beyond the industry norms for
compensating their selenium testers
provided they have the required
certifications and experience
the median salary of selenium testers in
the uk currently falls in the range of
40 000 pounds per annum to 65 000 pounds
per annum the average salary of a
selenium automation tester in the us is
around 97
500
per annum if we talk concerning india
the average salary of selenium tester is
19 lakhs per annum and the salary of a
selenium professional falls between 1
million per annum to 4.2 million rupees
per annum
this variation in salary depends on
various factors such as job location
experience education employer
certifications and many more
the salary trends give a great idea of
what you can expect from the carrier
so now when we know at what great height
is the demand of selenium in the market
let's go on and check the top 50
selenium interview questions
but before we begin make sure that you
have subscribed to our youtube channel
and hit that bell icon so that you can
never miss an update from simply learn
we have divided the questions into three
parts depending on the level of
difficulty okay without further ado
let's get started with our first part
that is the beginner level interview
questions
so the first question is what is the
main purpose of selenium
so the answer for this question is
selenium is an open source automated
testing tool used to test web
applications across various browsers
desktop and mobile apps cannot be tested
using selenium however other tools like
hp's qtp and appium can be used to test
software and mobile applications
it is a cloud-based testing platform
that allows testers to record their
actions and export them
selenium enables parallel test execution
which increases the efficiency of tests
selenium can test web applications
against browsers like firefox opera
chrome and safari to name a few
the test code can be written in various
programming languages like java perl
python and php selenium is platform
independent and can be deployed on
different operating systems like windows
linux and macintosh
selenium can be integrated with
third-party software tools like junit
and testng for test management selenium
is not just a single tool but a suit of
software each with different approach to
support automation testing it comprises
of four major components which include
selenium integrated development
enterprise selenium remote control now
deprecated
web driver and finally selenium grid
now moving on to the next question
what do you understand by automation
testing
automation testing uses automation tools
to write and execute test cases
in this case no manual involvement is
needed for executing an automated test
suit
testers prefer automation tools to write
test scripts and test cases and then
group them into test suits
automation testing enables the use of
specialized tools to automate the
execution of manually designed test
cases without any human intervention
automation testing tools may access the
test data control the execution of tests
and compare the actual result against
the expected result and finally
generating detailed test reports of the
system under test
now the third question is
what are the advantages of automation
testing
this is one of the most asked interview
questions in any automation testing job
some of the advantages of automation
testing are
the tool supports both performance and
functional testing it supports the
execution of parallel test cases it
enables parallel execution in the
combination of different operating
systems and browser environments there
is minimal manual intervention and test
scripts can be run unattended this
reduces the chances of human errors
there is reusability of code that is
create one time and execute multiple
times with less or no maintenance
automation testing saves time and money
and is faster in execution
in automation testing there are easy
reporting which means it generates
automatic reports after execution
it is easy for compatibility testing and
is cheaper compared to manual testing in
the long run automated testing is more
reliable more powerful and versatile
automation tools allow us to integrate
with cross browser testing tools jenkins
github etc
it is mostly used for regression testing
and supports execution of repeated test
cases
now moving on to the fourth question
what is the difference between selenium
2.0 and selenium 3.0
selenium 2 is nothing but integration of
webdriver with selenium rc or selenium
1.
selenium 1 is a well-established
framework that supports various browsers
due to its javascript implementation
the strengths of both the selenium web
driver and selenium one are combined in
silly name two
which makes it obvious that the
drawbacks were earlier there will no
longer be there in 2.0 on the other hand
in the case of selenium 3.0 selenium 3.0
can be referred to as an extended
version of selenium 2.0 solving bucks
and increasing stability
the big chance in the selenium 3.0 is
the core being replaced by backend web
driver it won't be wrong to say that
selenium 3 would be majorly be the
choice of software testing tool for both
web and mobile based applications
now moving ahead on to the fifth
question
what are the testing types supported by
selenium
so the answer for this question is
testing types that can be supported by
selenium are as follows
functional testing regression testing
re-testing acceptance testing end-to-end
testing smoke testing sanity testing
responsive testing cross-browser testing
ui testing integration testing
and many more
moving on to the next question
what are the different selenium suit
components so the answer for this
question is
there are four components in selenium
suit first is the selenium remote
control or selenium rc
selenium remote control enables the
writing of automated web applications in
languages such as java c-sharp etc
it is hardly in use today as the web
driver offers more powerful
functionalities
the second is the selenium grid selenium
grid enables the running of tests in
parallel on several machines
the commands are routed to the remote
web browser instances and one server
acts as the hub the hub is responsible
for conducting several tests on multiple
machines
the third is the selenium ide
selenium ide needs no additional setup
except installing the extension on your
browser the ide makes the test debugging
easier with features like setting
breakpoints and pausing exceptions
and the last and the fourth tool in the
suit is selenium web driver selenium
webdriver is the most critical component
of the selenium tool suit that allows
cross browser compatibility testing the
web driver supports various operating
systems like windows mac linux unix etc
now let's go on further and check the
next question
what are the different programming
languages browsers and operating systems
supported by selenium
so the answer for this question is
selenium supports various programming
languages to write test code with
language specific drivers that offer
commands from the selenium api the
common languages used by testers to
write selenium code are c sharp java
perl php python and ruby
java is the favorite language for use
with selenium one and two but the ease
of using python and ruby has led to many
testers opting for these languages as
well
so moving on to the next part of the
question which deals with the browsers
supported by selenium
the main reason for selenium's
popularity is the wide and comprehensive
list of features available on the
platform
with selenium test execution remains
seamless on just about all available web
browsers to name a few we have google
chrome mozilla firefox internet explorer
opera
safari and edge
so now let's talk with the respect to
operating systems that could be
integrated with selenium selenium
enables creating and testing suits on
any platform and executing their test
cases on different one
for example the tester could write test
cases using windows operating system and
then run them on a linux based operating
system
so to name a few selenium can support
android ios windows linux mac and
solaris
now let's go on and see the next
question
what are the advantages of webdriver
over selenium rc so the answer for this
question is webdriver is faster in
comparison to selenium rc because of its
simple architecture the web driver can
directly communicate to the browser
while selenium rc
needs the rc servers to help to do so
webdriver api is more concise than
selenium rc and can support html unit
while selenium rc cannot
selenium webdriver tool is used for
automating web application testing to
verify that it works as expected or not
it mainly supports browsers like firefox
chrome safari and internet explorer
it also permits you to execute cross
browser testing the next question here
is
why testers choose selenium over qtp so
the answer for this question is selenium
is an open source tool and it is
specifically designed to test web-based
applications
in selenium we can execute tests when a
browser is minimized whereas in qtp we
need to have an application under test
to be visible on the desktop in selenium
multiple cases can be executed in
parallel unlike qtp where we can execute
only one test at a time
there are several browsers supported by
selenium while qtp just supports
internet explorers on windows
selenium supports mobile devices like
android iphone blackberry headless
webkit whereas on the other hand qtp
uses a commercial product for mobile app
test automation that is hp uft mobile
selenium supports different programming
languages while q2p supports only visual
basic script and also selenium has zero
maintenance cost as it is open source
whereas qtp has a license and annual
maintenance charges
so now these were the few reasons why
testers mainly choose selenium over qtp
now moving ahead into our next question
what is the use of xpath
so the answer for this question is xpath
is a selenium technique used to navigate
through the html structure of a web page
it uses a non xml syntax to provide a
way of pointing to different parts of an
xml document
it can also be used to test address
nodes within a document to determine
whether they match a pattern or not
while other locators in selenium that
search for elements using tags or css
class names are simpler to use they may
not be sufficient to select all the om
elements of the html document
the primary purpose of xpath is to
address parts of the xml document now
moving on to the next question how can
you locate a web element in selenium so
the answer is selenium uses locators to
locate and identify web elements there
are different types of locators in
selenium some of the locators are
mentioned here
the first type of expert locator is the
id the best and the most popular method
to identify web elements is to use id
and obviously each element's id is
definitely unique the second type is the
class name
in this case the class name of the
element is used to find the element the
third type is the link test where the
text of the link is used to find the
element all the hyperlinks on a web page
can be identified using linked text the
links on the web page can be determined
with the help of anchor tag
the anchor tag is used to create the
hyperlinks on the web page and the text
between the opening and closing of
anchor tags constitutes the link text
then comes the xpath locator that uses
the name of the element to find that
particular element the other type of
xpath locator is the x path this
required to find the dynamic element and
to traverse between different elements
of the web page the last type of xpath
locator is the css path it locates the
elements to have no class name or id
now moving ahead into the next question
name the different types of webdriver
apis
so the answer for this question is the
webdriver api refers to the standard
that abstracts out the device or browser
specific bindings from the developer so
that the test script can be written in
any programming language and run on many
different browsers via a web driver
the different types of web driver api in
selenium are android driver chrome
driver event firing web driver firefox
driver html unit driver internet
explorer driver iphone driver iphone
simulator driver remote web driver
now moving ahead into the next question
what does a slash signify in xpath
and what is the difference between
single and double slash
the answer for this question is the
xpath syntaxes are path expressions that
are used for addressing into a document
slashes are used to create xpath with an
absolute or relative path xpath uses
path expressions to select notes in an
xml document
there are two cases
one is the single slash where the other
is the double slash single slash creates
xpath with an absolute path which means
that the x path would be made to begin
selecting from the start node
double slash on the other hand creates x
path with a relative path which means
that xpath would be made to begin
selecting from anywhere in the document
now moving on to the next question
explain absolute x-path and relative
x-path so the answer for this question
is absolute x-path starts from the root
node and ends at the desired descendant
elements node
it starts with the top html node and
ends with the input node
it starts with a single forward slash
as we discussed in the previous question
while on the other hand the relative
xpath begins from the middle of the html
dom structure relative xpath starts from
any node in between the html page and
the current elements node and it starts
with a double forward slash
then the other point of consideration is
the difference in the drawback and the
case of absolute x path is that if there
are any chances in the elements path
then xpath will fail and in the case of
relative xpath it enables writing from
the middle of the html dom structure
without any need to write the long x
path
we can see the syntax of the two
absolute xpath and relative xpath on
screen and we can notice the difference
in the slashes in case of both of them
now moving on to the next question name
some automation tools that can be
integrated with selenium to achieve
continuous testing
selenium can be integrated with several
automation tools some of them are maven
jenkins docker test ng
junit iphone driver iphone simulator
driver remote webdriver
now moving on to the next question
differentiate between verify and asset
commands
assets and verify methods are commonly
used in selenium for verifying or
validating applications
if the asset condition is true then the
program control will execute the next
step but if the condition is false then
the execution will stop and further test
steps will not be executed
whereas in the verifying condition there
won't be any pause in the test execution
even though the verify condition is true
or false there are two different types
of assets the heart acid and the soft
asset while there are no categories in
case of verification
the hard asset condition throws an
exception immediately after the asset
fails and carries out with the next case
of the suit on the other hand while the
soft asset condition does not throw an
exception immediately when the assertion
fails collects them and carries out with
the next validation
now moving on to the next question what
are the different types of junit
annotations which are used in selenium
junit annotation is a special form of
syntactic metadata that could be added
to java source code for better code
readability and structure annotations
were introduced in junit 4 which makes
the java code more readable and simple
the different types of junit annotations
are test
before after before class after class
ignore run with
now the next question in the docket is
how is test ng better than junit
test ng and junit are both open source
frameworks supported by selenium
webdriver
test ng is a testing framework based on
j unit and n unit to simplify a broad
range of testing needs from unit testing
to integration testing
there are more functionalities added to
test ng which makes it more powerful
than junit test ng enables dependency
testing which isn't there in junit now
moving on to the next question
what are the different types of selenium
frameworks
the selenium framework is what makes
code maintenance easy and efficient with
our frameworks users might place the
code and data simultaneously which is
neither reusable nor readable
there are beneficial outcomes or
frameworks like increased code
reusability higher portability reduced
script maintenance cost better code
readability and many more
there are three types of frameworks
created by selenium webdriver to
automate manual test cases the first
type is data driven the data driven
framework in selenium refers to the
method of separating data sets from the
test case
then the second framework is the keyword
driven framework this framework is a
method used for speeding up automated
testing by separating keywords for
common sets of functions and
instructions then the third framework is
the hybrid framework where we utilize
the advantages of both the keyword
driven framework as well as data-driven
framework
now let's move on to the next question
what is data-driven and keyword driven
data-driven framework is based on
several data sets generated in external
file and then imported to the automation
testing tool hence test data is
generated from external files like excel
csv or xml the data sets are separate
from the original script from which the
required input may be fetched
let's check on what is keyword driven
framework now
the idea behind the keyword driven
approach in automation is to separate
the coding from the test case and test
step
this helps a non-technical person to
understand the automation very well
the instructions required to perform the
operation are written in an external
file like excel sheet which keeps most
of the data and keyword driven which is
needed for the test like test case test
steps
test objects and actions
the functionalities to be tested can be
easily controlled by the users so this
was all about the beginners level of
interview questions
now let's go on further and check some
intermediate level of interview
questions that might help you take a
step further in your preparation
now the 21st question is what is
selenium webdriver
so the answer for this question is
selenium webdriver is the most important
component of the selenium tool suit
the webdriver allows cross browser
compatibility testing and supports
various operating systems like windows
mac linux unix and etc
it also provides compatibility with a
range of languages including python java
perl ruby etc
the web driver provides support for many
different browsers like chrome firefox
opera etc and provides faster execution
of the test scripts compared to other
tools the next question is what is the
need of selenium webdriver so the answer
for this question is
selenium webdriver provides a very
user-friendly interface that could be
easily understood
webdriver is a programming interface
that helps create and run test cases
it makes provision to act on web
elements the web driver has many other
features in comparison to selenium rc
and selenium ide
now moving on to the next question
how is the selenium webdriver different
from selenium rc and selenium ide
selenium webdriver is an open source
collection of apis which is used to test
web applications
the selenium webdriver tool is used for
automating web application testing to
verify that it works as expected or not
unlike the selenium ide selenium
webdriver can work with many different
browsers
then the webdriver does not require the
user to start the server as in case of
selenium rc
selenium webdriver is an api and not a
graphical user interface based plugin or
a standalone java application
in selenium webdriver all the apis are
entirely object oriented in nature
unlike the other tool in addition to
that selenium webdriver supports
listeners otherwise woes implementation
is not supported
the webdriver also supports ios and
android testing which is not supported
by rc and ide now let's move on to the
next question
what is the architecture of selenium a
web driver
selenium webdriver architecture in a
simplified diagram is shown on the
screen
selenium webdriver api enables
interaction between browsers and browser
drivers
this architecture consists of four
layers namely the selenium language
bindings json wire protocol browser
drivers and real drivers
selenium language bindings consist of
languages like java ruby python c sharp
and so on
after the test cases are triggered
entire selenium code will be converted
to json format
json stands for javascript object
notation
it takes up the task of transferring
information from the server to the
client json wire protocol is primarily
responsible for the transfer of data
between http servers generated json is
made available to browser drivers
through http protocol
each browser has a specific browser
driver
browser drivers interact with their
respective browsers and execute the
commands by interpreting json received
from the browser
as soon as the browser driver gets any
instructions they run them on the real
driver or browsers the response is given
back in the form of the http response
moving forward to the next question that
is the 25th question
what are the drawbacks of selenium
webdriver
selenium webdriver does not support
testing for desktop applications it
requires the expertise of team and
resources to manage
no inbuilt reporting capability test
reports are generated with the help of
plugins like junit and test ng and also
requires a lot of maintenance and it is
difficult to scale
if you want to get the technical issues
resolved one must trust the community
forums in selenium webdriver
testing of images is not possible for
testing of images integration of
selenium with sickly is needed
the next question is how does selenium
grid works so the answer for this
question is
selenium grid is a smart proxy server
that makes it easy to run tests in
parallel on multiple machines
this is done by routing commands to
remote web browser instances where one
server acts as the hub the hub is
responsible for conducting several tests
on multiple machines
now moving on to the next question what
are some of the common exceptions in
selenium webdriver the answer is
automation code execution usually may
not carry out as expected due to many
factors involved in execution such as
network stability issues internet issues
server stability etc
we might get exceptions due to
insufficient waiting time or incorrect
syntaxes parameters etc some of the most
common exceptions are
no such element exception no windows
exception
no such frames exception no alert
present exception invalid selector
exception
element not visible exception element
not selectable exception timeout
exception no such a session exception
now moving on to the next question
what is the difference between type and
type and weight command
so the answer for this question is
the two commands type and type and
weight command have their own specific
purpose the purpose of type command is
to type keyboard key values in the text
box the command can be used to select
the value of combo box whereas the type
in weight command is used when the
typing is completed and the web page
starts loading the command waits for the
software application page to reload now
the next question
what is the difference between find
element and find elements in selenium
here the find element command is used to
identify a web element within a web page
it returns the first web element that
matches the search in case there are
multiple elements and throws an
exception called
no such elements exception if the
element is not found whereas the find
elements command is used to identify a
list of web elements within a page it
returns the list of elements that match
more than one element and does not throw
an exception but returns an empty list
if there are no matching elements
now moving on to the next question
what is meant by weight in selenium how
many types of weights are there in
selenium
the weight functions are very essential
when it comes to executing selenium
tests
they help in observing and
troubleshooting the issues that may
occur due to variation in long time
in automation testing
weight commands direct the test
execution to pause for a certain length
of time before moving on to the next
step there are two types of weight
commands they are the implicit weight
and the explicit weight first we will
learn the implicit weight implicit
weights tell the web driver to wait for
a certain amount of time before it
throws an exception
once we set the time webdriver will wait
for the element based on the time we set
before it throws an exception the
default setting is zero we need to set
some wait time to make webdriver to wait
for a required time
now we will learn about the explicit
weight the explicit to weight in
selenium is used to tell the web driver
to wait for a certain condition or
maximum time exceeded before throwing an
exception that is the element not a
visible exception
moving on to the next question
what is the biggest disadvantage of
implicit weight
the main disadvantage of the implicit
weight is that it slows down the test
performance webdriver will wait for some
specific amount of time before it throws
an exception for example if you set the
waiting time to be 10 seconds and the
elements appear in the dom in 11 seconds
your test will fail because you told to
wait for a maximum of 10 seconds only
now moving on to the next question what
are the type of navigation commands
so the different types of navigation
commands are the first one
driver.navigate
to url
this navigates to the provided url
then comes driver.navigate.refresh
this method refreshes the current page
the third command is the driver dot
navigate dot forward this method does
the same operation as clicking on
forward button of any browser it neither
accepts nor returns anything
last navigation command is the driver
dot
driver.navigate.pack
this method does the same operation as
clicking on the back button of any
browser it neither accepts nor returns
anything
moving on to the next question
what is meant by same origin policy and
how is it handled
same origin policy is a feature taken
for security purposes
according to this policy a web browser
enables the access of scripts from one
web page to the other if both the pages
have same origin
the origin policy protects a malicious
script on one page to access sensitive
data on another
followed by this we have the next
question
what is salinas and how is it classified
sillyness is a set of selenium commands
which are used to test your web
application
testers can test the broken links the
existence of some objects on the ui ajax
functionality alerts on window list
options and lot more using cylinders
selenium commands tells the selenium
automation engine to perform certain
tasks cylinders can be classified into a
set of three types of commands which are
action
accessors and assertions
moving ahead we have the 35th question
what is the difference between
driver.close method and
dot quit method
so the answer for this question is the
driver.close command is used to close
the current browser window if there are
multiple windows open on the screen then
the one on focus will be closed whereas
the driver.quit command is also used for
the same purpose if there are multiple
browser windows open on the screen then
the command closes all of them at once
moving ahead we have the advanced level
of interview questions
now we are done with the intermediate
level of selenium interview questions
let's now buckle up a little more and
learn the advanced level of interview
questions the first question in this
category is how do you type text in an
input box using selenium
the method used to type text in input
boxes is send keys the send keys method
allows typing automatically into an
editable field during the execution of
any tests
these fields are web elements that can
be identified using locators like
element id
name class name etc
now moving on to the next question how
to click on a hyperlink in selenium
the command used to click on the
hyperlink uses link text to find the
element the command finds the element
using linked text and then clicks on the
element
where after the user would be redirected
to the corresponding page
you can find the syntax of the command
on the screen
moving on to the next question how to
scroll down a page using javascript
the method used to scroll down to a page
is scroll by
we can see the syntaxes of a set of
commands the first syntax that is the
execute script here is the general
syntax for scroll by command
then the second syntax of javascript
executor is create a javascript object
then the third syntax driver.get is the
syntax of launching the desired
application then the last syntax that is
the js dot execute script is for the
scroll down to the desired location
moving forward we have the next question
what is the way of typing in a text box
without using send keys
the text can be entered into a text box
by using javascript executor the
commands that could be used for the
process can be seen on the screen you
can use javascript executor and
jse dot execute script for the work to
be done now moving forward we have the
next question how to select a value from
a drop down in selenium web driver
for selecting and deselecting from a
drop down in selenium web driver select
class is used the objects of select type
can be initialized by passing the drop
down web element as a parameter to its
constructor the syntax of the commands
can be seen on the screen the web
element test drop command and the
command to select the drop down here the
web driver offers three ways to select
from a drop down box the first way is to
select a buy index that is the selection
is based on index starting from zero
then comes select by value that is
selection based on value the last way is
select by visual text that is selection
of option that displays text matching
the given argument the next question is
what is the use of switch to command the
answer for this question is the switch
to command is used to switch between
windows frames or pop-ups within the
application
every window instantiated by the web
driver is given a unique alphanumeric
value called window handle we can see
the syntax of commands on the screen
the first command that is the string
handle command is used to get the window
handle of the window you wish to switch
to and then the driver dot switch to
command is used to switch to the desired
window
the next question is what is meant by
object repository in selenium webdriver
an object repository is a common storage
location for all objects
if we talk in the context of selenium
webdriver these objects would typically
be the locators used to identify web
elements uniquely for example if there
is a chance in one web element's locator
value then only the object repository
has to be changed instead of all the
test cases
the object repositories have to be built
in selenium webdriver using the key
value pair approach
the two types of object repositories may
be created in selenium webdriver are the
first one object repository using
properties file and the next one object
repository in xml
moving ahead we have the 43rd question
how to upload a file in selenium
webdriver
to upload a file in selenium webdriver
the send keys or robot class method are
used the initial step is to first locate
the text box and then set the file path
using send keys method and click on
submit the syntax for the command can be
seen on the screen
the first syntax of the web element
command is used to locate the browse
button then the second syntax of the
browse dot send keys is used to pass the
file path to be uploaded using sendkeys
method moving on to the next question
what is the way to set browser window
size in selenium
so the answer for this question is the
window size can be maximized set or
resized to maximize the window we use
the driver.manage.window.maximize
method or command
and
then to set the window size we can use
dimension d is equals to new dimension
wherein the brackets we give the
dimensions we want to set the size
now moving on to the next question how
can you debug tests in selenium ide
the steps to debug the test and selenium
ide are the first step is to insert a
breakpoint from the place you want to
execute your test then execute the text
case after the test case has started
executing the execution will pass at the
breakpoint then click on the blue button
with the next statement to continue and
finally click on the run button to
execute all the commands
moving ahead we have the next question
how to insert a breakpoint in selenium
ide
the steps to insert a breakpoint in
selenium ide are the first step is to go
into the selenium ide right click on the
command and select toggle breakpoint
then select the command and press the b
key on the keyboard pause that to clear
the breakpoint press b key again
and multiple breakpoints can be set up
in the selenium ide moving forward we
have the next question what is a pause
on an exception in selenium ide so the
answer for this question is
the pause on an exception is a feature
that is used to handle exceptions in
selenium ide the feature can be used by
clicking on the pause button on the
right top corner of the ide window the
execution stops when an exception is
encountered and the script enters to the
debug mode so the entire test does not
fail and the error can be resolved
moving forward we have the 48th question
what can result in the failure of
selenium ide
so the answer for this question is
selenium ide is one of the most
accessible record and plato's in the
selenium tool suit which requires no
particular setup the selenium ide comes
with a very rich set of commands powered
by surnames and allows us to record and
test different web application
interactions with the browser but then
there are certain times when the
selenium ide might fail some of those
instances are when selenium cannot
locate the element if the locator has
changed then
one more such instance is when the
element to be accessed cannot be found
on the web page and operation is timed
out and one more case is when the
element being tried to access is not
created
for finding if the link is broken or
working fine we use the driver.get
method when we use driver.getmethod to
navigate to a url it will respond with a
status of 200 okay 200 ok
denotes that the link is working and it
has been obtained if any other status is
obtained then it indicates that the link
is broken some of the http status quotes
are 200 that indicates it's a valid link
4.4 indicates link not found 400
indicates bad request 401 indicates
unauthorized
and finally 500 that indicates internal
error
and now we are at the last question
how to login to any site if it is
showing an authentication pop-up for
username and password so the answer for
this question is to handle
authentication pop-ups we need to verify
its appearance and then handle them
using an explicit weight command the
syntax of the explicit weight command to
be used is on the screen that is
the first syntax webdriver weight syntax
the second syntax is the alert alert
equals to weight dot until refers to the
use of alert class to verify the alert
and the last syntax is alert dot
authenticate that is there to provide
the credentials after the verification
in the previous step welcome to this
video on the interview questions of
configuration management tools chef
ansible and puppet
chef is a configuration management tool
written in ruby and erlang which
provides continuous deployment
increases system robustness and provides
cloud integration
ansible is another open source software
tool for provisioning configuration
management and application deployment
and puppet is a configuration management
tool that can also be used as a
deployment tool and implements
infrastructure as a code in this video
we have compiled the most important
interview questions of configuration
management tools chef ansible and puppet
that you might face in a devops
interview
so without further ado let's get started
so let's just get into the first section
which is configuration management so one
of the questions that you'll get asked
right away is why do you have ssl
certificates used for chef really
fundamentally your immediate answer
should be security ssl provides for a
very high level of private security and
private and public key pairing this
really is essential to ensure that you
have a secure environment throughout
your entire network the second part
should be that if you're using ssl and
you're using the private public key
model within ssl you're able to
guarantee the systems on your network
that the chef that you'll be able to
validate that the nodes within your
network that chef is validating against
actually are the real nodes themselves
not imposters so you will also be asked
some questions such as the following
which is the following commands would
you use to stop or disable the http
servers when the system boot and you'll
typically get four responses and
there'll be
system ctl disable http dot service or
is it system disable http dot service
system disable httpd or the final option
which is system ctl disable
httpd.service
your answer should be the first one
which is hashtag system ctl disable
http.service
so chef comes with a series of tools
that allow it to function effectively
and one of the tools that you're going
to be asked about is what is test
kitchen and test kitchen is essentially
a command line tool that allows you to
be able to test out your cookbook before
you actually deploy it to a real note so
some of the commands that you would use
are for instance if you want to create
an instance of test kitchen you would do
kitchen create if you want to destroy an
instance after you created it you do
kitchen destroy and if you want to be
able to combine multiple instances you
would do kitchen converge so a question
you'll get is around chef is how does
chef apply differ from chef client so
fundamentally the difference between
them is that chef apply will validate
the recipe that you're working on
whereas chef client looks to apply and
validate the entire cookbook that's run
in your server environment so one is
focused on the recipe and the other is
focused on the entire cookbook
so there are some differences when
you're working with different command
lines so for instance when you're
working with puppets and you're working
with one version of puppet and you want
to do what is the command to sign a
requested certificate the top example
here is for public version 2.7 whereas
the lower option here is for puppet
version 3. and that's something to bear
in mind when you're going through your
interview process is that the tools that
are used within a continuous integration
continuous delivery devops model do vary
and so you want to be able to talk
knowledgeably about the different
versions of the tools so that when
you're talking to your interviewer
you're able to show the deep knowledge
that you have
which open source or community tools do
you use to make puppet more powerful and
essentially this question is going to be
asking you to look beyond the core
foundation of puppet itself and so the
three options you have is being able to
track configurations with jira which you
should be doing anyway but it's a great
way to be able to clearly communicate
the work that's being done with puppet
our version control can be extended with
get and then the changes should be
passed through jenkins so the three
tools you want to be looking at
integration with jira git and jenkins so
what are the resources in puppet well
fundamentally there are four the
resources are basic units of any
configuration management tool they are
the features of the nodes they are the
written catalog and the execution of the
catalog on a node so as we dig deeper
into puppet one of the things that you
are likely to be asked regarding puppet
is what is a class in puppet and so a
class in puppet is really the name
blocks in your manifest that contain the
various configurations and this can
include services files and packages and
we have on the screen here an example of
what a class would look like when you
write it out and you may want to
memorize just one class don't memorize
just a whole set of classes just
memorize one the person that's
interviewing you is just really looking
for someone who has a working knowledge
they're not looking for you to have
memorized complete massive classes but
having one small class to be able to
illustrate the experience you have is
extremely valuable to the interviewer
particularly if it's a technical
interview so as we move into ansible one
of the things that you're going to be
asked around ansible is what is ansible
role so a role is an independent block
of tasks and variable files and
templates embedded with inside of the
playbook so example we have here on the
screen actually shows you one role
within a playbook and in this role it is
to install tomcat on a node again as
with previous question within puppet of
a class it's probably good to have
memorized just one or two roles so you
can talk knowledgeably about ansible
when you're having your interview so
when you're working with ansible when
should you be using the curly brackets
and so just as a frame of reference uh
there's often two different ways that
these kind of brackets are referred to
and they're either referred to as french
brackets or curly brackets either way
and what you'll be wanting to answer is
when would you use these specific types
of brackets within ansible and really
the answer comes down to two things one
is that it makes it easier to
distinguish strings and undefined
variables and the second is for putting
together conditional statements when you
are actually using variables and the
example we have here is this prints the
value of and we have foo and we have to
then put in the variable conditional
statement of foo is defined as something
so what is the best way to make content
reusable and redistributable with
ansible and there's really essentially
three the first is to include a
sub-module or another file in your
playbook the second is to import an
improvement of an include which ensures
that a file is added only once and then
the third is roles to manage the tasks
within the playbook
so a question you will be asked is
provide a differences between ansible
and puppets so if we look at ansible
it's a very easy agentless installation
it's based on python you can configure
it with yaml and there are no support
for windows in contrast puppet is an
agent-based installation it's written in
ruby the configuration files are written
in dsl and it has support on all popular
operating systems so we dig deeper into
the actual architecture ansible it has a
much more simple architecture and it's
definitely a push only architecture in
contrast to puppet it's a more
complicated but more sophisticated
architecture where you're able to
have a complete environment managed by
the puppet architecture
docker is a popular devops tool used to
automate the deployment of applications
in lightweight containers so that
applications can work efficiently in
different environments
docker was initially released in 2013
and since then has become the go to
solution for containerization
in this video we have compiled the most
important docker interview questions
that you might face in a docker or
devops interview
so without further ado let's get started
so let's go through and you're going to
be asked to explain what the
architecture of docker is and docker
really is the most popular
containerization environment so docker
uses a client server architecture and
the docker client is a service which
runs in a command line and and then the
docker daemon which is run as a rest api
and within the command line will accept
the requests and interacts with the
operating system in order to build the
docker images and run the docker
containers and then the docker image is
a template of instructions which is used
to create containers the docker
container is an executable package of
applications and its dependencies
together and then finally the docker
registry is a service to host and
distribute docker images among other
users so you'll also be asked to provide
what are the advantages of docker over
virtual machine and and this is
something that comes up very
consistently in fact and you may want to
even extend it as having what are the
differences between having a dedicated
machine a virtual machine and a docker
or docker-like environment and really
the the arguments for docker are just
absolutely fantastic you know first of
all docker does contain and occupy
socket containers occupy significantly
less space than a virtual machine or a
dedicated machine the boot up time on
docker is significantly faster than a vm
containers have a much better
performance as they are hosted in a
single docker image docker is highly
efficient and very easy to scale
particularly when you start working with
kubernetes easily portable across
multiple platforms and then finally for
space allocation uh docker data volumes
can be shared and reused among multiple
containers the argument against virtual
machines is significant and particularly
if you're going into an older
environment where a company is still
using actual dedicated hardware and
haven't moved to a cloud or cloud-like
environment your arguments for docker
are going to be very very persuasive be
very clear on what the advantages are
for docker over a virtual machine
because you want to be able to
succinctly share them with your team and
this is something that's important when
you're going through the interview
process but also equally important
particularly if you're working with a
company that's transitioning or going
through a digital transformation where
they aren't used to working with the
tools like docker you need to be able to
effectively share with that team what
the benefits are so how do we share
docker containers with different nodes
and in this instance what you want to be
able to do is leverage the power of
docker swarm so docker swarm is a tool
which allows the it administrators and
developers to create and manage clusters
of swarm nodes within the darker
platform and there are two elements to
the node there's the manager node and
then there's the the worker node the
manager node as you'd assume manages the
entire infrastructure and the working
node is actually the work of the agent
as it gets executed
so what are the commands to create a
docker swarm and so here we have an
example of what a manager node would
look like and once you've created a
swarm on your manager node you can now
add worker nodes to that swarm and again
when you're stepping through this
process be very precise in the execution
part that needs to be taken to be able
to effectively create a swarm so start
with the manager node and then you
create a worker node and then finally
when a node is initialized as a manager
node it can immediately create a token
and that token is used for the worker
nodes and associating the ip address
with the worker nodes question 17 how to
run multiple containers using a single
service it is possible to run multiple
containers a single service by using
docker compose and docker compose will
actually run each of the services in
isolation so that they can interact with
each other the language used to write
out the compose files that allow you to
run the service is called yaml and yamos
stands for yet another markup language
so what is the use of a docker file so
dockerfile actually is used for creating
docker images using the build command so
let's go through and show on the screen
what that would look like and this would
be an opportunity where if you're
actually in a technical interview you
could potentially even ask hey can i
draw on a whiteboard and show you what
the architecture for using the build
command would look like and what the
process would look like um again when
you're going through an interview
process as someone who interviews a lot
of people one of the things i really
like is when an interview candidate does
something that's slightly different and
in this instance this is a great example
of where you can stand up to the
whiteboard and actually show what can
actually be done through actually
creating images on the whiteboard very
quickly little square boxes where you
can actually show the flow for creating
a build environment as an architect this
should be something that you're
comfortable doing and by doing it in the
interview and suddenly you want to ask
permission before you actually do it but
doing this in the interview really helps
demonstrate your comfortable feelings of
working with these kind of architecture
drawings so back to the question of
creating a docker file so we go through
and that we have a docker file that
actually then goes ahead and creates the
docker image which then in turns creates
the docker container and then we are
able to push that out up to a docker hub
and then share that docker hub with
everybody else as part of the docker
registry with the whole network so what
are the differences between docker image
and docker containers so let's go
through the docker image so the docker
images are templates of a docker
container an image is built using a
docker file and it stores that docker
file in a docker repository or a docker
hub and you can use docker hub as an
example and the image layer is a
read-only file system the docker
container is a collection of the runtime
instances of a docker image and the
containers are created using docker
images and they are stored in the docker
daemon and every container is a layer is
a read write file system so you can't
replace the information you can only
append to it
so while you can actually use yaml or
writing your so a question you can be
asked is instead of yammer what can be
an alternate file to build docker
compose so yaml is the one that is the
default but you can also use json so if
you are comfortable working with json
and my that is something that you should
get comfortable with is you want to be
able to use that to name your files and
as a frame reference json is a logical
way of being able to do value paired
matching using a javascript like syntax
so you're going to be asked to how to
create a docker container so let's go
through what that would look and we'll
break it down task by task so the task
is going to be create a mysql docker
container so to do that you want to be
able to build a docker image or pull
from an existing docker image from a
docker repository or hub and then you
want to be able to then use docker to
create a new container which has my
sequel from the existing docker image
simultaneously the layer of read write
file system is also created on top of
that image and below at the bottom of
the screen we have what the commands
lines look for that so what is the
difference between a registry and a
repository so let's go through that so
for the docker registry and repository
for the registry we have a docker
registry is an open source server-side
service used for hosting and
distributing docker images whereas in
contrast for repositories a collection
of multiple versions of a docker image
in a registry a user can distinguish
between docker images with their tag
names and then finally on the registry
docker also has its own default retreat
called docker harb for the repository it
is a collection of multiple versions of
docker images it is stored in a docker
registry and it has two types of public
and private registry so you can actually
create your own enterprise registry so
you're gonna be asked you know what are
the cloud platforms that support docker
really you know lists them all and we
have listed here amazon web services
microsoft azure google cloud rackspace
but you could add in their ibm bluemix
could put in red hat really any of the
cloud service providers out there today
do support docker it's just become an
industry standard so what is the purpose
of expose and publish commands in docker
so if we go through expose is an
instruction used in docker file whereas
publish is used in docker run command
for expose it is used to expose ports
within a docker network whereas with
publish it can be used outside of a
docker environment for expose it is a
documenting instruction used at the time
of building an image and running a
container whereas with published is used
as to map a host port to a running
container port for expose is the command
used in docker whereas for publish we
use the command-p for when we're doing
our command line used in docker and
examples of these are expose 8080 or
with docker we would put in or for
publish would do the example docker run
and then 0.0.0.80
a colon80 as our command line hello and
welcome to kubernetes interview
questions now the great thing about
being a kubernetes expert is that there
is a growing market for people wanting
to hire you and you're going to get
asked a lot of questions in this video
we're going to take you through the 13
most common questions that you are
likely to be asked in a kubernetes
interview as always if you like this
video we have the subscribe button below
and then the like button that will
notify you of all new videos as they get
submitted also if you have any questions
feel free to post those into the
questions below and we'll get back to
you with answers we try and answer as
many questions as possible so without
any more hesitation let's jump into some
of the popular interview questions that
you're going to get asked we're going to
break up the interview questions into
three categories it's going to be
beginner intermediate and advanced um
the beginner questions are really going
to cover about three quarters of the
questions that we're going to ask here
and then the intermediate and advanced
will finalize out the we'll finish out
the final quarter and and the reason is
is that quite typically
most interviews you'll be asked you know
intermediate to beginner level questions
mainly beginner level questions just so
you can demonstrate your understanding
of kubernetes and then there's always
one advanced question that gets thrown
out just to make sure that you really do
know what you're talking about and
you've done at least one or two
kubernetes environment uh setups to be
able to validate your experience so
let's kind of jump into that first
section which is you know why is
kubernetes widely used and your answer
to this really comes into the fact that
kubernetes is widely used because of
three distinct areas one is that
kubernetes is an open source platform
that is readily available for the
management containers and allows you to
manage the deployment scaling and
management of those containers and so uh
the first area is that it allows you for
easy deployment of your containers the
ability to scale effectively within
kubernetes not just vertically but
horizontally for your containers and
then finally the kubernetes environment
itself was really designed to make it
easy to manage containers um in small
parts other key areas of why kubernetes
is popular is that kubernetes is the
single largest open source project out
there since its launch in 2014 is just
grown in leaps and bounds um around that
project there is just a huge community
both an online and physical community
there are just a large number of online
groups that are supporting kubernetes
and allow you to get fast access to
information but in addition to that
there are also a lot of
local meetup groups that cover
specifically kubernetes whether as part
of a devops group or as part of a
dedicated kubernetes group the actual
environment itself is a really robust
way of being able to manage your
containers containers are becoming the
most popular way of being able to deploy
cloud-based applications kubernetes is
an effective and persistent storage
environment so kubernetes is also able
to effectively manage persistent storage
whether it's local storage as a ssd
drive or a local hard drive or whether
it's cloud-based storage and because of
the way that kubernetes architecture is
really designed for the cloud from the
ground up so it's a great way to get
started in building out your cloud
solutions and then finally the actual
tools within kubernetes are designed to
help and manage the health and
monitoring of the environment itself so
what is google container engine so the
google container engine is another open
source solution but it's designed for
managing the docket containers and
clusters and so kubernetes is a
container management solution and docker
is the most popular container solution
out there and this is just a way of
being able to bring the two effectively
with into each other so that you can
have docker containers manage the
application and then kubernetes manage
the scale of your applications as
they're vertically and horizontally
scaled across your network so what is
the difference between kubernetes and
daca and this is important because
kubernetes and docker are often dropped
in the same sentence and there's a lot
of people that get confused between the
two so fundamentally kubernetes is about
taking pods which contain containers
which have applications in and deploying
them at scale across a cloud network
docker is the container solution itself
so the actual application itself is put
into the docker container because of
this difference kubernetes is designed
for auto scaling is highly available
whereas docker simply isn't because it
doesn't have to worry about that within
the container itself the kubernetes
environment will check for liveness and
readiness of the health of the entire
infrastructure whereas with docker it's
just really going to check the services
that are coming in and out of the actual
application itself within the container
kubernetes is complicated to set up it
really is just simply complicated setup
and what you'll find is a lot of cloud
services will actually do the setup for
you whereas docker is very easy to set
up the as you would expect with the
tolerance ratio there is high fault
tolerance with kubernetes whereas with
docker is low fault tolerance again this
is fundamental in the two different
types of strategy that kubernetes and
docker have they're both connected
tightly with each other but they both do
different things so what are the notable
features of kubernetes and one is the
ability to do container variants
kubernetes always knows where to place a
container within its entire network
within the pods and with his
infrastructure the services are managed
for security network and storage uh it
is self monitoring so it goes in and is
able to check its own nodes for health
and the containers within the nodes so
it makes sure that the applications are
always running effectively you can do
the scaling effectively both vertically
and horizontally within kubernetes the
solution is open source so there's no
actual fee for the actual kubernetes
service itself and kubernetes allows for
storage orchestration what does they
mean by storage orchestration now
storage orchestration is that you're
able to
access and share either local storage
such as a hard drive or ssd drive or a
cloud-based drive and my preference is
always to go with cloud-based drive
because then you're really positioning
your solution to be a true cloud-based
application so what are the main
advantages of kubernetes
where you get automatic rollback for
changes that go wrong the
you're able to automate a lot of the
processes that would have been manual
processes previously
you're able to scale the resources both
vertically and horizontally easily and
quickly and then these three areas the
rollback automating role bank automating
services and being able to scale
indirectly allows you to save money by
reducing the amount of time of people
working on your operations environment
so let's break out the architecture of
kubernetes so you're going to be
explaining us to explain
how is kubernetes
architecture structured and there are
three key areas there's the application
layer there's the kubernetes layer and
then there's the infrastructure layer
we're gonna start off with the
infrastructure layer and so the
infrastructure layer is our base layer
and this is where all your where you
make your clusters for your collections
of storage and networking resources
within kubernetes and this is where you
would have if your databases are your
data stored locally on a hard drive or
in the cloud your core network and the
vms that you'll be building out your
infrastructure on these allow you to
group many machines together into a
single unit so that you're able to scale
up and down very easily to meet customer
demand so let's talk about the middle
layer which is the kubernetes layer now
so if we're looking at our architecture
for our kubernetes layer it's really
broken down for the the core operating
system the docker container environment
and the kubernetes code itself and this
is where you're able to take machines
and pull them together as a cluster so
that they work within that kubernetes
system you have a master controller
within kubernetes that actually then
will go ahead and manage the scheduler
control manager the api server and then
you'll be able to cluster all of these
kubernetes together so that they're all
working and processing as one single
unit and then finally let's look at the
application layer where you actually
have your apps and so the application
layer uh where you have your pool and
your services you know kubernetes will
use api to connect in and out of this
layer it's to run your applications
within containers and you use
instructions that are written in yaml or
json to actually
set up those containers and you actually
have the environment running on a plan
that examines these instructions so it
keeps the entire environment healthy api
ecosystem is used to interact with the
cluster it's so you don't have to
do that by yourself so make sure that
you're referencing that the apis are
secured and connecting in and out of the
system and so you have your
scheduling control manager actually from
the kubernetes environment doing the
hard work and then the workers
themselves execute the the commands that
are coming from kubernetes so you will
be asked to kind of dig into some of the
key areas such as explaining the master
node and listing
its components so the master node is
comprised of four key components there's
the uh cluster store the controller
manager uh the scheduler and the api
server so four key point components
remember four fingers four components
and then you're gonna be asked to maybe
dig deeper into what is a cluster within
kubernetes and so a customer is really a
combination of resources such as
machines into a single node and then
those nodes are pulled together and work
as a single cluster as a whole
kubernetes will work with that whole
cluster and then and once you're
actually working with that whole cluster
if a node fails or needs to be removed
kubernetes is able to do that quickly
and effectively so let's talk a little
bit about what are the different types
of controllers in kubernetes and there
are five types of control manager uh you
have the node controller the service
account the token controller the
endpoint controller and the replication
controller and so the node controller
controls and handles the node in the
system the service account enables
access controls in the system the token
controller cleans up any tokens for
non-existent service accounts the
endpoint controller joins services in
pods to the endpoint objects and the
replication controller manages the pod
lifecycle so what is the role of the
cloud controller manager within this
environment and so the role the cloud
control manager is really to help manage
persistent storage and so persistent
storage is storage that's either local
storage to the physical machine such as
an ssd or hard drive or cloud-based
storage and this allows the storage to
be shared across the entire network what
is the role of the cube api server and
the cube scheduler so the cube api
server responsible for the establishment
of communication between the kubernetes
nodes and the master components and and
it does this through the through apis
the apis themselves are all commands
that are rest based commands and it
implements an interface which means
different tools and libraries can
communicate effectively with each other
so what is the role of the cube api
server and the cube scheduler so the
cubes capture actually does the
distribution of work across the entire
infrastructure so the actual
yaml scripts that you've written are
executed appropriately at the right time
so you're going to be asked to explain
persistent volumes in kubernetes so a
persistent volume is just a place where
you can store data again this can be
local data as in a hard drive local to
the physical machine or it can be
cloud-based data so what is a cube light
and a cube proxy so a cube light is a
service responsible for conveying
information to and from the control plan
itself the process and the acute proxy
itself is responsible for maintaining
the work and the standards within the
node server in addition every node in
the cluster runs a simple network proxy
and queue proxy routes requests to the
correct container in that node in
addition you'll have some basic and
primitive load balancing and management
of the node from the proxy itself and
there's additional layers of management
that get done outside of the proxy but
the proxy is also there to help do some
localized load management so what is
cube ctl so cube ctl is your command
line or terminal window interface that
allows you to execute commands and later
uh in this video we'll actually go
through some of those commands etcd is
the store that configures the details
and essential values such as key value
pairs that are distributed across your
entire network it also manages the
network rules and the post forwarding of
activity so what are the disadvantages
of kubernetes well the first is it's
really hard to install and configure and
this is why azure and many cloud
services such as google cloud will
actually do the installation and
configuration of kubernetes for you it
does take a long time to get up and
running with kubernetes not so much for
the actual software but your own
experience of being able to use
kubernetes it is not simple to manage
the service you actually have to have a
lot of experience and this is why people
get paid a lot for kubernetes skills
it's a difficult environment to get up
and running and be effective in that
management again kubernetes is just not
an easy platform to learn it takes a lot
of time and effort and
one of the disadvantages is that while
kubernetes itself is free because it is
an open source project getting the
people who are skilled you to using
kubernetes is expensive all right so
those were kind of the introductory um
questions that you can expect to be
asked in your interview the next set of
questions are really going to be on an
intermediate and advanced level and
these are the questions that will be
thrown out you know you see these as
being the trick questions which are
really there to test that you have the
skill set to be able to implement and
manage kubernetes within a company so
what happens if a master node fails what
happens if a worker node fails how would
kubernetes manage that well kubernetes
is really designed for this kind of
scenario and so you can actually look at
it and the response would be is that the
pod itself does not get affected
kubernetes will actually respond and fix
the uh the failed node whether it is uh
needs to be repaired whether it needs to
be restarted or needs to be replaced so
what is a service role in kubernetes so
a service role is an abstraction for all
the pods it provides a virtual ip
address and allows clients to connect to
containers running in the pods using
that virtual ip address and the command
that you would use to get that we would
use some of these cube ctl commands it's
quite a simple one it's cube ctl get
services and you get a full list then of
all the services that are available so
how do i do a rollback in deployment and
so there's a couple of ways you can do
the rollback and the first is if you
want to see the rollout history
deployment you would write cubectl
rollout history deployment and then in
square brackets deployment if you want
to just restore to the previous rollout
the command would be cubectl rollout
undo deployment and then in square
brackets deployment and that would take
you back to the previous deployment so
what is an ingress controller so an
ingest controller really is a part that
manages that inbound traffic and a
prominent feature of that traffic is
that it is secured with an ssl
termination and so what we're going to
do to now address some of the key ways
in which you can provide api securities
on kubernetes and we have eight of those
uh so the first four are
implementing tl tls for your security
the second would be api authentication
the third is to make the cubeless
protection the cubeless
protected via authorization
mode equals webhook command the fourth
is to monitor rbac failures the fifth is
to remove those default service account
permissions
six would be to filter egress to cloud
api metadata apis the seventh is to use
pod security policy to restrict
container policies and protect the node
and the eighth and final is to keep the
cube at the latest version all right
let's go into some of the more advanced
commands and so the advanced questions
you're going to get are all going to be
commands that you're going to be asked
to write now my advice for you for these
questions is to make sure that you have
some of these basic commands memorized
they don't have to be perfect when
you're in the interview
environment but it's good to be able to
get up to a whiteboard and actually
write out what these commands are just
so you can actually demonstrate that you
know what the commands are the interview
isn't going to ask you questions on how
would you
apply kubernetes to the company that
you're being hired for because you
simply don't have that knowledge but
they do want to be able to see clearly
that you understand the commands and
terminal window instructions that will
be able to demonstrate how you would
actually go in and access some of that
information so one of the first
questions you might be asked is how do
you package kubernetes applications and
so you would use the package manager
within kubernetes to be able to manage
to and configure and deploy applications
into your cluster and so here we have
the the helm command that you would use
so what are in it containers and any
container gets executed before any other
containers can run on the pod and so you
want to be able to illustrate
what the init instructions would look
like and here we have an example and i
would again uh use this example and
maybe memorize it for when you have this
question come up in your interview so
what is the difference between a config
map and a secret and these are more uh
fundamentals so a config map just has
the instructions that are clearly
available in plain text on what the
cube is supposed to do whereas
the secrets are actually encrypted and
these are
like uh passwords and other sensitive
data that you don't want to have um
easily available these are encrypted
information have to be decrypted to
access the content so if a node is
tainted is there a way to schedule the
pods to that node and the answer is no
there isn't and so what you have to do
then is schedule the pod to be
fixed and so that schedule the pod to
fix the tainted node to allow for
tolerations to that and we have here the
example code that you would use to do
that so how do you deploy a feature with
zero downtime in kubernetes well
kubernetes is designed to be able to
roll out um applications with zero
downtime and here we have four examples
using the rolling update as a strategy
for zero downtime uh deployments in
kubernetes again memorize one of these
so you can actually illustrate how you
use rollout to be able to deploy a zero
downtime solution so how do you monitor
a pod that is always running and so to
do that you would use the liveness probe
to check um the health of the
application within the pod and see
whether or not
there are any failures or whether or not
the part itself needs to be restarted so
how do you drain traffic from pot during
a maintenance so again um this is a
simple command for you to remember but
to be able to drain an application so
that it's easy for you to be able to do
maintenance on the application you would
use the cube ctl grain and then in
square brackets the node name and that
would then
temporarily drain
that
particular parts you can actually do
maintenance on it what you have to then
and this would probably give you bonus
points with your in an interview is then
uh reference the uncorden command so
that you can uncordon the actual
node itself so that the part itself can
come back up into life and work as a
fully functioning solution so to be able
to tie surfaces to a positive to a set
of parts you can apply labels to the
actual parts themselves and then use the
labels as selectors to be able to glue
services to that pod and again we have
here an example of how you'd actually do
that and again this is one of those
where you can probably won't be asked to
write this out but it'd be good to have
this memorized how would you get all
parts on a node and so the following
command will actually go ahead and bring
all the pods into a kubernetes cluster
um this is quite lengthy and you know
maybe you want to like talk to how this
would be done but we have the
instructions on how to do that right
here the important part is to make sure
that you are when you're talking about
the node name that you reference to
whoever you're interviewing that you
would what you would switch out to
reference the actual nodes that you're
trying to pull together into the
kubernetes cluster so how do parts mount
nfs volumes and so in these examples
here we actually define the nfs server
and then the pod and how you'd actually
mount two together and again what you
want to be able to do is illustrate why
you would use yaml and
how you'd actually then point to
specific ip addresses within your
kubernetes environment within either the
production or test environments to be
able to illustrate how you would mount
up those nfs volumes
nagios or nagios core is a free open
source computer software that is used to
monitor systems networks and
infrastructure
nagios was initially released in 2002
and since then has become the go-to
solution for monitoring in the devops
lifecycle
in this video we have compiled the most
important nagios interview questions
that you might face in the nagios or
devops interview
so without further ado let's get started
so let's look at continuous monitoring
so with continuous monitoring how does
negatives help in continuous monitoring
of systems applications and servers and
so this is really just a high-level
question of using nagios within your
environment and you should be able to
just come back very quickly and say
nagios allows you to help manage the
servers and check if they're being
sufficiently utilized and if there are
any task failures that need to be
addressed and so there are three areas
of utilization and risk that you want to
be able to manage this is being able to
verify the status and services of the
entire network the health of your
infrastructure as a whole and if
applications are working properly
together with our web services and apis
that are reachable
so the second question you'll be asked
is how does negatives help in continuous
monitoring of systems applications and
services so it's able to do this by
having the initial negatives process and
scheduler and the additional plugins
that you would use for your network
connect with the remote resources and
the negative web interface to be able to
run status checks on a predefined
schedule so what do you mean by nagios
remote plugin executor or the mpre of
netgears so mpre allows you to execute
plugins on links unix machines that
allow you to do additional monitoring
and machine metrics such as disk usage
cpu load etc
what are the ports used by nagios for
monitoring purposes in this example
there are three and they're easy to
remember so i would memorize these three
but they're essentially ports five six
six six
five six six seven and five six six
eight so there are two types of checks
within that year so you will be asked
for what is an active and passive check
in nagios so an active check and is
initiated by the nagios process and is
run on a regular schedule a passive
check is initiated and formed by an
external application or process so this
may be where a system is failing and
checks are results are submitted to
nigeria's for processing and to continue
with this for what is an active and
passive check active checks are
initiated by the check logic within the
nagios daemon negatives will execute a
plug-in and pass information about what
needs to be checked plug-in will then
check the operational state of the host
or service and then process the results
of the
host or service check and send out
notifications in contrast with the
passive check it is an external
application that initiates the check it
writes the results of the check to an
external command line file and i guess
reads the external command file and
places the results of all passive checks
in a queue for later processing so you
can go back and revalidate and then
negotiate may send out notifications log
alerts etc depending on the results that
they get from checking the information
so you're going to be asked to explain
the main configuration file and its
location in nagio so the main
configuration file consists of a number
of directives that affect how nagios
operate so consider this as the
configuration file that's read by both
nagios processor and the cgis so this
will allow you to be able to manage the
main configuration file that's placed
into your settings directory so what is
the nagios network analyzer and again
hold out your four fingers because there
are four options here so the nagios
network analyzer are one provides an
in-depth look at all your network
traffic source and security threats two
allows system admins to gather
high-level information on the health of
your network three provides a central
view of your network traffic and
bandwidth data and then four allows you
to proactive in resolving outages
abnormal behavior and threats before
they affect critical business processes
so what are the benefits of http and ssl
certificate monitoring with nagios so
with http certificate monitoring it
allows you to have increased server and
services and application availability
obviously very important fast detection
of network outages and protocol failures
and allows web transaction and web
service performance monitoring the ssl
certificate monitoring allows you for
increased website availability frequent
application availability and provides
increased security so explain
virtualization with nagios so in
responses the first thing you should be
able to talk about is how naive itself
can run on many different virtualization
platforms including microsoft visual pc
vmware zen amazon ec2 etc etc so just
make sure you get that right off the bat
now yes it was able to provide
capabilities tomorrow assortment of
metrics on different platforms it allows
for ensure for quick detection of
service and application failures and has
the ability to be able to monitor
against many metrics including cpu usage
memory networking and vm status so name
the three variables that affect
recursion inheritance in nagios and it
is name use and register so name is a
template name that can be referenced in
other object definitions use specifies
the name of the template object that you
want to inherit its properties and
variables from and register indicates
whether or not the object definition
should be registered to nagios and on
the right hand side of the screen we
have an example of what that script
would look like again you may want to be
able to memorize this as it's something
that you can actually write down and
show someone if you're going through a
technical interview so why is nagios
said to be object oriented and
fundamentally comes down to the object
configuration format that you can use in
your object definitions it allows you to
inherit properties from other object
definitions and this is typical of
object-oriented development and is now
applied for the nagios environment so
some of the objects that you can inherit
are services hosts commands and time
periods so finally explain what is state
talking in nagios and so there are
really four options here when you're
talking about state stalking so state
stalking is used for logging purposes in
nagios it allows you to enable for a
particular host or service that nagios
will watch over very carefully it will
log any changes it sees in the output of
the check results and then finally helps
the analysis of log files
jenkins is a popular devops open source
automation server
it is used to automate the non-human
part of software development and
supports continuous integration and
continuous delivery
jenkins is a server based system that
runs in servlet containers such as
apache tomcat
we have compiled the most important
jenkins interview questions that you
might face in a jenkins or devops
interview
so without further ado let us get
started with jenkins interview questions
and answers so the first question you'll
be asked about with jenkins is explain a
master slave architecture of jenkins so
the way that jenkins is set up is that
the jenkins master will pull code from
your remote git repository such as
github and will check that repository
every time there is a code commit it
will distribute the workload of that
code and the tests that need to be
applied to that code to all of the
jenkins slaves and then on request the
jenkins master and the slaves will then
carry out all the builds and tests to be
able to produce test reports the next
question you'll be asked is what is a
jenkins file and simply put a jenkins
file is a text file that has a
definition of the jenkins pipeline and
is checked into a source code repository
and this really allows for three
distinct things to happen one it allows
for a code review and iteration of the
pipeline it permits an audit trail for
that pipeline and also provides a single
source of truth for the pipeline which
can be viewed and edited so which of the
following commands runs jenkins from the
command line is it java jar jenkins dot
war java dash war jenkins.jar
java.jar jenkins.jar java dashwar
jenkins.org
and the answer is a java dash jar
jenkins.war so when working with jenkins
you're going to be asked what are the
key concepts and aspects of working with
a jenkins pipeline and you want to
really hold out your fingers here and go
through
four key areas and that is pipeline node
step and stay so pipeline refers to the
user-defined model of a cd continuous
delivery pipeline node are the machines
which is which are part of that jenkins
environment within the pipeline step is
a single task that tells jenkins what to
do at that particular point in time and
then finally stage defines a
conceptually distinct subset of tasks
performed through the entire pipeline
and tasks could be build test and deploy
so which of the following file is used
to define dependency in maven and do we
have a build.xml
b
palm.xml c
dependency.xml or d
version.xml and the answer is palm.xml
working with jenkins you're going to be
asked to explain the two types of
pipeline used in jenkins along with the
syntax and so a scripted pipeline is
based on groovyscript as their domain
specific language for jenkins and there
are one or more noteblocks that are used
throughout the entire pipeline on the
left hand side you can actually see what
the actual script would look like and
the right hand side shows what the
actual declaration for each section of
that script would be the second type of
jenkins pipeline is a declarative
pipeline and a declarative pipeline
provides a simple and a friendly syntax
to define what the pipeline should look
like and then you can actually at this
point use an example to actually break
out how blocks are used to define the
work completed in a decorative pipeline
so how do you create a copy and backup
of jenkins well to create a backup
periodically back up jenkins to your
jenkins home directory and then create a
copy of that directory it's really as
simple as that a question you'll be
asked as well is how can you copy
jenkins from one server to another well
there essentially there are three ways
to do that one is you can move a job
from one installation of jenkins to
another by copying the corresponding job
directory the second would be to create
a copy of an existing job directory and
making a clone of that job directory but
with a different name and the third is
to rename an existing job by renaming a
directory so security is fundamental to
all the work that we do within devops
and jenkins provides the center core to
all the work that gets completed within
a devops environment there are three
ways in which you can apply security to
authenticate users effectively and when
you're asked about this question of
security within jenkins the three
responses you want to be able to provide
is a jenkins has its own internal
database that uses secured user data
from end user credentials b is you can
use a ldap or lightweight directory
access protocol server to be able to
authenticate jenkins users or see you
can actually configure jenkins to
authenticate by using such as oauth
which is a more modern method of being
able to authenticate users you're going
to be asked how to deploy a custom build
of a core plug-in within jenkins and
essentially the four steps you want to
go through are first of all copying the
dot hpi plugin file into the jenkins
home plugins subdirectory you want to
remove the plugins development directory
if there is one you want to create an
empty file called
plugin.hpi.pinned and once you've
completed these three steps restart
jenkins and your custom build plugin
should be available how can you
temporarily turn off jenkins security if
the administrative user has locked
themselves out of the admin console this
doesn't happen very often but when it
does it's good to know how you can
actually get into jenkins and be able to
resolve the problems of authenticating
effectively into the system as an
administrator so when you want to be
able to get into a jenkins environment
what you want to be able to do is locate
the config file you should see that it's
set to true which allows for security to
be enabled if you then change the user
security setting to false security will
disabled allow you to make your
administrative changes and will not be
re-enabled until the next time jenkins
is restarted
so what are the ways in which a build
can be scheduled and run in jenkins well
there are four ways in which you can
identify the way a build can be
scheduled on running jenkins the first
is when source code management commits
new code into the repository you can run
jenkins at that point the second can be
the after the completion of other builds
so maybe you have multiple builds in
your project that are dependent to each
other and when so many other builds have
been executed then you can have jenkins
run you can schedule build to run at a
specified time so you may have nightly
builds of your code that illustrates the
changes in the solution you're building
and then finally you also can manually
build a environment on request
occasionally you will want to also
restart jenkins and so it's good that
when a question around how do you
restart jenkins manually comes up that
you have the answers and there are two
ways in which you can do it one is you
can force a restart without waiting for
bills to complete by using the jenkins
url that you have for your environment
slash restart or you can allow all
running builds to complete before
restart are required in which case you
would use the command of the url for
your jenkins environment
safe restart now with that we have come
to an end of day 6 and also the devops
week by simply learning hope the week
was informative and interesting if you
have missed out on any of the sessions
then please feel free to check them out
in our official youtube channel the link
to which is in the description box below
and if you have any queries then please
leave them down in the comment section
below and our team of experts will be
happy to resolve all your queries hoping
to see you again on another exciting
learning week by simply learn until next
time thanks for watching don't forget to
subscribe to stay tuned for more from
simply
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
you